all right my my name is Nick parks and
Gary I'm just curious so let's say if um
you know you were just born to be an
entrepreneur that's just what you do I'm
sure I believe in that um well until
you're an entrepreneur like that you're
just you're not going to be fulfilled uh
you're going to be happy but to me about
my first 18 years of my life yeah so
that's my question like at what point
are you being fiscally responsible and
at what point are youing is it just like
analysis paralysis where you think well
I can't go into it full-time yet I still
need a full-time job that's a question I
I now I understand what you're saying so
so are you saying let me make sure I
dissect this properly for people like me
that happen to feel that they are that
and then happen to be good at it it's
easy right because it worked out are you
asking me if you feel like you're an
entrepreneur but you're not good enough
to be an entrepreneur that can sustain a
lifestyle where you have to balance
something else what do you do maybe or
do you keep trying or are you asking
actually apologize cuz now I'm recal
calibrating how long can I you know go
at it as thinking I'm an entrepreneur
until I have to wake up and say wait a
minute am I tricking myself and let me
get a little more practical and jump off
that train um I mean more like let's say
you have a full-time job and it's good
pay good benefits and all that if you
have a full-time job you're not an
entrepreneur so you have to understand
that is a very important part here right
you may have entrepreneurial Tendencies
You may have aspiration to be an
entrepreneur but when you are an
entrepreneur you can't breathe having a
job you can't breathe you have to
understand you can't breathe now look
maybe the extreme of it but you know the
fact is you know especially right now
and especially if I'm guessing at some
level this is for you not your friend
kind of thing or it might be friend or
it might be General you're so young that
you have so much less risk than the like
when you're 18 to
29 in America today by all standards to
me that's your time to if you're an
entrepreneur you're being an
entrepreneur right you know if you're
ready and willing to take a job then you
have entrepreneurial Tendencies and
that's the thing you have to figure out
but to me there is no such thing as an
under 30-year-old entrepreneur that has
a job it doesn't exist all right thanks
all right man thanks oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
Social